[Musik]
guten tag für ihre zuschauer entsetzen
fassungslosigkeit
tiefer schock die usa sind am nachmittag
ziel mehrerer terroranschläge geworden
die zahl der toten könnte möglicherweise
in die zehntausende gehen angefangen
hatte die verheerende serie in new york
innerhalb weniger minuten stürzten zwei
flugzeuge in die türme des world trade
zentrums beiden bürotürme sind
inzwischen zusammengebrochen
um 16 30 fiel auch der zweite turm des
world trade centers in sich zusammen
nichts ist mein new york wie sie mal war
20 jahre später das malerische dorf
geplant in südnorwegen
56 einwohner rund 6000 kilometer
luftlinie von new york city entfernt ein
ort der susanne hegenscheidt geholfen
hat die traumatischen erlebnisse eines
tages in new york city zu verarbeiten
der sie und die welt für immer verändert
hat der elfte september
der tag war eigentlich wunderschön das
waren ein spätsommertag blauer himmel
überhaupt gar keine wolke das sollte
sehr warm werden an dem tag und
ja man hatte das gefühl ja schöner
altweibersommer wie man auf deutsch
sagen würde und man hätte überhaupt
nicht denken können dass an dem tag so
eine katastrophe passiert
7 und 59 in boston startet united
airlines elf mit ziel los angeles an
bord mohammed atta eine der 19
terroristen die an dem morgen insgesamt
vier verkehrsflugzeuge entführen und als
tödliche waffen einsetzen mein freund er
war schon zur arbeit gefahren der
arbeitete in mitfahren und ich wollte
auch zunächst erstmal ins world trade
center um mir eine deutsche zeitung zu
kaufen
da hörte ich plötzlich ein tiefflieger
und dachte noch so mein gott fliegt ja
viel zu tief das hier ist ein dicht
bebautes gebiet der hat sich wohl
verflogen oder so und dann hört man
und in dem moment als der das flugzeug
in den tower hereingeflogen ist aber ich
bin natürlich zum fenster gegangen und
habe diese lose gezogen und habe dann
diese aufschlag
explosion gesehen und da habe ich
natürlich einen unglaublichen schrecken
bekommen dachte aber zunächst das sei
ein unfall gewesen
susanne lebt in unmittelbarer nähe der
zwillingstürme am kopf der wall street
sie schreibt ihrem bruder eine e-mail um
die mutter zu beruhigen sie hat die mir
bis heute aufgehoben sendedatum elfter
september 2001 5 nach 9 uhr ortszeit
hallo matthias vor etwa zehn minuten ist
entweder ein flugzeug in den zweiten
teil von world trade center gerauscht
oder eine bombe explodiert hier ist die
hölle los ich habe gesehen wie die
trümmer vom tower vielen und die
menschen um ihr leben gerannt sind
überall flog papier durch die luft die
oberen stockwerke des towers
einzubrennen polizei und feuerwehr fährt
gerade auch es ist ein unbeschreibliches
chaos der garten der trinity church vor
unserem fenster ist weiß von papier ich
habe ein paar bilder gemacht
gerade ist ein zweites flugzeug in den
ersten folge flogen das ist ein direkter
angriff keine ahnung wer das macht
flugzeuge sind direkt bahrain geflogen
es brennt im ersten teil der flügel hat
etwa die mitte gestreift man wusste
nicht dass ich so eine angst haben kann
es ist schrecklich hier brad ist auf dem
weg zur arbeit in der subway ich bin
okay aber angst was als nächstes
passiert die leute haben gerade
angefangen zu arbeiten sagte ich bin
natürlich susanne
su sanne schnapp ihren fotoapparat
steigt aufs dach zusammen mit einer
gruppe von bauarbeitern sieht sie durch
das teleobjektiv ihre kamera bilder die
sie nie vergessen wird ich konnte eben
sehen wie
dinge aus den zerborstenen
fenstern aus den stockwerken
herausfielen das war sehr viel papier
aber es waren oft größere gegenstände
ich habe den arbeitern zu berufen da
springen die menschen raus und und dann
haben wir alle zusammen gebetet also
jeder hat gebetet und ich hier
etwas kritisches verhältnis zu gott und
so vorher hatte habe gemerkt dass ich in
dieser
unglaublich verdichteten
erschreckende situation beete und beete
und beete und für jeden einzelnen der da
springt
augenzeugen auf der straße geraten in
panik susanne will unbedingt zu ihrem
freund dann erschreckt sie ein
dröhnender krach es gab einen
ohrenbetäubenden ganz ganz
seltsames kniffs geräusch
sowas gab es vorher und auch wieder nach
gehört
und dann stürzte der astra zusammen in
sich zusammen und das kam diese
unglaubliche druckwelle und diese
wahnsinnige rauch und aschewolke
auf uns zu bewegt also auf das gebäude
in dem ich gewarnt habe zugelegt und ich
habe automatisch immer nur auf den
kamera auslöser gedrückt und habe das
aber gar nicht gemerkt ich war es so
starr vor angst bis dann die wolke
direkt vom fenster war und dann der
blitz automatisch an gegangen ist und
wer hat mich quasi wieder rausgeholt aus
meiner aus meiner
sie pacta stick einen rucksack mit
reisepässen wasser zieht sich turnschuhe
an flieht auf die straße sie rennt um
ihr leben
als ich dann draußen direkt vor unserem
haus stand properties ring
brach der zweite tower in sich zusammen
und die druckwelle hat mich von den
füßen gerissen und ich lag auf dem bauch
auf meine kamera in dieser
grau-schwarzen auch dunkelheit
und dachte im ersten moment jetzt bin
ich
mit tausenden kämpft sie sich durch die
dichte wolke richtung midtown erst am
nächsten tag wird sie erfahren dass
terroristen ins pentagon geflogen sind
und das mutige passagiere ein entführtes
flugzeug in shanksville pennsylvania zum
absturz gebracht haben bevor es ins
weiße haus legen konnte inmitten der
fliehenden aus der asche wollte fühlt
sich susanne unglaublich allein
die new yorker haben sich in den tagen
und in den wochen und monaten nach den
anschlägen ja miteinander verbrüdert und
solidarisiert und mitgeholfen und so
weiter nur unmittelbar in den stunden
nach diesem anschlag da waren wir alle
alleine alle waren so sprachlos man ist
nie gekommen ich bin nicht auf die die
idee gekommen aber auch die anderen sie
gingen alle alleine und ich glaube dass
zumindest für mich das auch für die
jahre danach bedeutete
dass sich da einen schrecken festgesetzt
hat weil ich den nicht sofort loswerden
konnte ein trauma nicht nur für susanne
ein trauma für amerika das glaubte auf
eigenem boden unangreifbar zu sein bis
heute sehen amerikaner die angst vor
terroranschlägen als eine der zwei
größten bedrohungen die allermeisten
menschen die einen traum erleben
dass ein teil seiner
selbst
der person die du in dem moment bist die
bleibt darin gefangen die kommt nicht
raus das heißt du entwickelst dich
weiter du lebst da weiter das leben geht
weiter jetzt sind es 20 jahre ja ich bin
jetzt in einem ganz anderen setting hier
nicht mehr new york ich lebe jetzt in
norwegen auf dem land nicht mehr
großstadt und so aber ein teil von mir
ist in new york geblieben der ist bei
diesen menschen die aus den tauern
herausgesprungen sind geblieben der ist
immer noch da und er holt mich auch
manchmal meinen träumen ein nur tage
nach den terrorattacken leidet susanne
an lähmungserscheinungen
sie zittert die junge frau kann
zeitweise nur noch mit hilfe eines
rollators gehen
heute lebt susanne auf dem land im
friedlichen norwegen und zuteilung von
ihren posttraumatischen
belastungsstörungen mit ihren kindern
wohnt sie auf einem bauernhof
[Musik]
ground zero die wunde im herzen
manhattans das heute von new yorker
haben einen ort an dem sie der opfer
gedenken können was hat sich an elfter
september für susanne geändert
wenn ich mir die bilder die ich an dem
morgen in manhattan gemacht habe
anschaue dann
überkommt mich eine gänsehaut ein
kribbeln eine aufregung und es wundert
mich manchmal dass es nach 20 jahren
immer noch so ist aber wie gesagt die
weltordnung sie war an dem tag vorbei
das ist
als wäre die kindheit plötzlich vorbei
als wäre die unschuld vorbei und es wird
nie wieder so sein und deswegen bewegt
mich dieser tag so unglaublich und immer
noch nach 20 jahren mit all den folgen
dieses für mich persönlich hatte und für
die ganze welt
den jahrestag will susanne mit freunden
und nachbarn im dorf verbringen am
elften september will sie ihnen erzählen
dass sie vor zwanzig jahren erlebt hat
ein weiterer schritt auf dem weg ihr
trauma zu überwinden
ganz weit weg von new york in den
norwegischen fjorden